in this video we'll be talking about
thymic aplasia and this is a high topic
for usml step one so stay tuned till the
end of this video thas is a organ which
is the training school for T lymphocytes
it's basically a primary lymphoid organ
which helps in the development of the t-
cells so inside the thas the tea cells
undergo specific training known as
thymic selection and there are specific
lessons which are learned by these t-
cells there is positive selection which
teach the t- cells to recognize peptides
from an MHC molecule and there is
negative selection which tells the t-
cell not to recognize self
peptides if presented on an MHC that is
why thymus is really important for t-
cell production and overall immune
response and in thymic aplasia thymus
development is abrogated there is
underdevelopment or complete absence of
the thymus in most of the cases there is
an underdevelopment of the thymus this
is associated with a s syndrome known as
djor syndrome and it is commonly
associated with the micro delions
associated with 22nd chromosome 22 Q
11.2 to be more
specific now DJ Syndrome has different
clinical presentation this particular
summarize the clinical presentation
always remember Catch 22 C for cardiac
defects there are several cardiac
defects that are associated with dord
syndrome which we will talk in a moment
but there is ventricular septal defect
atrio ventricular Canal defect there
could be also tetrology of fell truncus
arteriosus
Etc now there's abnormal facial features
which are associated with dord syndrome
you can obviously see this cartoon and
get some idea about it there would be
thymic hypoplasia under development of
the thymus there could be Cliff pellet
that means the upper part of the pellet
is not uh joined properly there could be
hypocalcemia which is a result of a
parathyroid hormone uh disbalance and
ultimately 22 stands for the 22 Q uh
11.2
deletion let's talk about these symptoms
in bit more details so there are number
of facial features which are kind of uh
defective in this part particular
individuals there are hooded eyes
relatively long face small and low set
ears enlarged nose tips short WID of the
eye opening
Etc obviously if you just look at them
they are not normal and this dis
disorder is typically associated with a
micro delion which roughly contains
about 50 genes one such Gene which is
present in this particular location is
known as tbx1 Gene tbx Gene product is
really important
in specific stages of embryonic
development when the facial features
heart thyroid and parathyroid hor glands
are actually developing so the third and
the fourth fenial pouch is highly
enriched in this tbx1 expression and
especially in dord syndrome there is a
defect in third and fourth fenial pouch
formation now tbx1 is highly expressed
during different stages as we mentioned
so the stages include facial feature
form formation heart thyroid and
parathyroid even thymus formation this
explains why dgs patients are presented
with uh symptoms of imuno deficiency
because the thymus is abated or thymus
is
malformed there are several Heart defs
Like ventricular septal defect that you
can see here and also there is arterio
ventricular Canal defect that can be
depicted
here now there are other clinical
presentations like like the Clift plet
generally the there is a Clift in the
upper
plet and this can lead to several other
problem like speech or swallowing could
be an issue for these babies although
DJs sufferers show many degree of immune
deficiencies the degree varies widely so
all the immune deficiencies are not
similar in very rare cases U the thic
tissue is uh not present but in most
most of the cases to some extent thymus
is present but in a very minuscule
format so anyway be the thermos thymus
is present or not present the te- cell
production and the t- cell formation is
abrogated so when te- cells are not
present there could be bacterial and
fungal infection there could be
infection from opportunistic pathogens
so thymic transplantation and passive
antibody treatment could add value to
the individual's life and quality of
Lifestyle so I hope this video was
useful if you like this video give it a
quick thumbs up don't forget to like
share and subscribe see you in next
video you can support our Channel using
super thanks which is present in the top
right corner of the video by clicking on
it you can pay via PTM PayPal or UPI see
you in next
[Music]
video